when it comes to Joe Koy I think
comedians should stay away from that
because when it comes to something that
mainstream said at that time of the day
how funny can you really be comedy is
about pushing the boundaries so how much
is mainstream TV going to allow you to
push the boundaries my mom used to tell
me when I was little any publicity is
good publicity you know what I'm saying
like controversy creates clicks so I
understand why they're doing it right
like I feel like comedy's the last
actual art the last actual Freedom right
but you go in a realm of which is not
Comics they're gonna judge you I think
it should all be AI hosts I should it
should be AI hosts just leading off
reading off like uh intensive lists of
allegations associated with everyone in
every project that's even mentioned on
the broadcast if at the very least it
should be scrolling across the bottom I
was talking to people at the Sellar
about how difficult is it's a no- win
situation comedians stay the away from
the Golden Globes